[Music]
we've got more presidents week in
partnership with learn liberty foria
today that's five shows in five days
with five experts on five different
presidents of the United States joining
me today is a professor of political
philosophy at Clemson University the
executive director of the Clemson
Institute for the Study of capitalism
and the author of two books on John
Adams see bradlee Thompson welcome to
the Rubin report hi Dave it's great to
be here with you I've seen the studio
many many times and it's great to
finally be here well it's great to have
you here you know out of all of the
professors that I'm talking to you this
week you're the only one that I've met
before and we've worked together before
yeah we did an event at Clemson of
course with Jordan Peterson and on car
gate from Iran Institute and just very
briefly before we dive into John Adams I
just when I left that weekend and Jordan
I talked about it after I just thought
what you guys were doing there was
spectacular the amount of young people
talking about freedom I'm talking about
capitalism you took us to a little event
in the afternoon with some of your top
tier students and we sat around and just
talked about ideas and they had great
questions so just very briefly can you
just kind of tell me about what you're
doing there and then and then we'll talk
about yeah yeah absolutely so I think in
your interview with Jordan Peterson and
Ben Shapiro a couple of days ago you
mentioned an idea revolution and and I
think that's precisely what we're trying
to do at Clemson so in addition to being
a professor political philosophy I run
the Clemson Institute for the Study of
capitalism and the Institute is
America's first and only university
based teaching and research center
dedicated to exploring the moral
foundations of a free society and more
recently in the last three or four years
we've started a brand new program called
the Lyceum Scholars Program and what it
does is it offers a scholarship to
incoming freshmen and we use a great
books approach to studying the history
of Liberty capitalism the American
Founding and the principles of moral
character
and there's simply no program in the
United States like this it's it's the
students are required to take eight
classes together as a cohort one each
semester over their four years and we're
trying to create a new kind of
intellectual community one that is based
around big ideas great books and in a
genuine interest in the history and
development of the idea of freedom yeah
well it was just very obvious to me and
to Jordan that you guys were just doing
great work I mean just the questions we
were asked even I had a few hours in the
afternoon I was just wandering around
campus and kids were coming up to me and
asking me you know it's one thing they
wanted to say I take it something but
they really wanted to talk about
politics I was like this is this is
absolutely amazing so so good work well
thank you and we have to have you back
yeah we'd love to have you back with
Jordan and and and others and and and
you also work with Brandon Turner by the
way yes the former guest of the Reuben
board and also a great professor yeah
Brandon is a member of the Clemson
Institute and a good friend
great all right so let's talk John Adams
yeah so we're doing a lot of founders
this week not not all founders but the
three really James Madison Thomas
Jefferson and John Adams yeah I think I
actually know the least about John Adams
out of the three so this is going to be
a little bit of a learning experience
for me too you've written two books on
John Adams so first off the way I've
started all these is just a little bit
on the brief history just as a young
person what do we need to know well but
before I start with Adams as he as a boy
in a young man let me just begin with a
kind of controversial claim in my view
of the Adams is the most important the
most accomplished of all of America's
founding fathers I think this can be
demonstrated it's provable and hopefully
over the course of the next hour so
we'll find out so and I think Adams was
the revolutions greatest man of ideas
and I think he was the greatest man of
and we'll talk about that I talked about
that over the course of our time who was
John Adams born in 1735 in Braintree
Massachusetts he was the son of a farmer
and a shoemaker so he came from very
very modest means he was raised in a
Calvinist
Puritan culture he was home-schooled
essentially until he was 16 first just
in as his parents home and then as I
think starting maybe as an eight year
old boy he would go to a local literally
a home school right where someone would
take in four or five students and teach
them in their home
he went to Harvard when he was 16 and it
was at Harvard though that you really
see the flowering of a new person as a
result of a kind of intellectual
confrontation with the Enlightenment so
raised in as I said in this Calvinist
Puritan family and culture gets to
Harvard and he's introduced to the ideas
of the Enlightenment more particularly I
would say he's introduced to two books
that that change his life the first is
Newton's Principia Mathematica and the
second is John Locke's essay concerning
human understanding and from Newton he
learns that the universe is governed by
by universal absolute physical laws of
nature from Locke he learns that he
learns the possibility of what we might
call a the creation of a demonstrative
or secular science of ethics so he
combines these two ideas when when he
when he's at Harvard and he starts to
think seriously about developing a kind
of naturalistic moral philosophy right
after he graduates from Harvard he takes
a job as a as a schoolmaster in a
one-room schoolhouse
in Worcester Massachusetts and if you
think about it where is Worcester
Massachusetts in in 1757 it is literally
on the western frontier of civilization
certainly yeah British civilization and
so here here he is in a village of maybe
five hundred people in a one-room
schoolhouse for a couple of years
teaching eight-year-old boys and there
are great stories that he tells in his
diary about his experience during that
time and I have to say I mean it mirrors
my own my own life I taught for two
years at an all-boys boarding school
teaching teaching young boys and I can
tell you you have to learn to grow up
real fast trying to teach young boys
well much of anything yeah and so it was
during this time during this two or
three-year period that he's in Worcester
Massachusetts that that John Adams young
John Adams who's now say 21 years old is
really starting to think about who and
what he is and wants to be so he begins
a diary and in this diary he you know
first he confronts his Puritan
background and there are there are
tortured passages where he's really try
he's wrestling with the foundations of
Calvinist theology and and ultimately he
comes during these years he finally
comes to reject Calvinist theology so he
rejects the idea of total depravity
original sin unconditional elections and
and he really sort of embraces the idea
that that you can through primarily
through reason through introspection and
one's observation of the world that you
can develop a moral philosophy
I mean Adams was Adams was always
religious beginning to end but he really
did think it was possible to develop
what we might call the secular science
of ethics yeah that's really interesting
let's just pause there for a second
because I think that's one of the themes
that we talked about on this show a lot
right people of faith and not of faith
who are constantly trying to figure out
well where do morals come from and he
remained a religious person and also I
was I'm gonna read a specific quote to
you in a little bit
yeah about his feelings on that but then
also did acknowledge the separation of
church and state to which is sort of but
although maybe not as specifically as
perhaps Thomas Jefferson right James man
which is a really interesting little
piece yeah and and I mean through
studying John Adams and and particularly
studying him at this age so when he's in
his early 20s I mean you you you really
see it's a kind of pivotal point in
American history when we went when
Americans colonial Americans transition
out of particularly those in New England
when they transition out of their
adherence to this Calvinist theology to
becoming you know essentially a kind of
enlightenment nation and and and so he's
he's struggling with his religion he's
struggling with how to how to establish
this kind of demonstrative science of
ethics and what he does is he in this in
part he gets from Locke and Newton is
it's the study of human nature and how
do you study human nature well the first
thing you do is you introspect you turn
inward you look look inward on yourself
right and you you try to figure out who
and what you are and and what your
motives are when you act and and how it
is and why it is that you get angry in
certain situations and and and the
results the effects that certain kinds
of behaviors have on other people then
the second thing is you just look out
into the world right and you observe
other people and so for instance in his
diary he has passages where he just a
young man where he describes a fight a
conjugal fight between his parents and
it's it's clearly upsetting to him he
goes upstairs to his bedroom and he sits
down and then he writes out a long
passage describing
the passions that affected both of his
parents and how one can overcome those
passions and then the third vehicle by
which you can study human nature he says
is by studying history history is a kind
of laboratory for studying human nature
history is in a sense for Adams
philosophy by example and so he slowly
in the late seventeen fifty s develops
this sort of moral philosophy that is
that is that is focused on his own
individual development his the primary
virtue of the what we might call the
architectonic virtue is self-governance
right how do you govern yourself and and
he developed a series of virtues
connected with self-governance which is
it's very interesting that that he does
this at that age he was 21 when he
starts this and instead of saying part
because Benjamin Franklin when he was
the same age as Adams decides that he
wants to achieve moral perfection and
you can read about this in in Franklin's
autobiography which and if you think
about it I mean this is extraordinary
and Adams was concerned but the same
thing moral perfection how do I become
if not morally perfect the the most
virtuous kind of person that that I can
be or one can be Franklin develops a
sort of like a pre Jordan Peterson
thirteen step program for moral
perfection he establishes thirteen
virtues and he creates a chart right by
which one can can practice each week one
one virtue and you go it's a it's
literally a thirteen step program to
moral perfection and John Adams does
something very similar to that
and it's I mean people always ask ask me
the question how is it why is it that we
got this extraordinary generation of
revolutionary leaders right Adams
Washington Franklin Jefferson Madison
Hamilton that were often very separate I
mean Geographic absolutely they were all
separate right but it all in the end I
think I mean the explanation for how and
why we got this generation at one moment
in time is is the moral education that
they all undertook when they were very
young men and that was a big part of of
18th century American culture the focus
the really intense focus on one's more
own moral development yeah it's
interesting because we could use
probably a little more in that these
days but as you just referenced Jordan
Peterson I think that has a lot to do
with all the reasons that he's catching
fire yeah no he is so I wanted to read
this quote to you because I think it
gets right to what you're talking about
and and the play that John Adams had
with religion which is so interesting to
me this quote he said our Constitution
was made only for a moral and religious
people it is wholly inadequate to the
government of any other
that almost sounds a little reverse of
the way the rest of the founders might
have viewed religion and government do
you think that's a fair estimation um no
I think that probably would have been
shared by most of of the revolutionary
generation because it says a moral and
religious people now they were
separating church and state but I guess
morality was tied so into religion at
the time either way although he was
working on this way sort of to solve
that problem yeah I mean I I think the
view of the entire revolutionary
generation is that you can't have a you
can't have a free society made up of
moral reprobates right and so for the
founding generation there was there
there must be a connection between moral
virtue in a free society so in many ways
I mean they're of course best-known to
us
by what they created politically right
by by the Constitution and the
revolutionary state constitutions but in
in many ways I think their greatest
contribution which we have entirely
neglected in the in the late 20th and
now in the early 21st century is their
understanding of morality right now
we're all of them five-point Calvinists
no somewhere were all of them atheists
well even fewer were atheists even
Thomas Jefferson who probably came the
closest to to you know not being
religious believed him even Jefferson
himself believed that that most people
needed religion of some kind right in
and they had I mean we'll take Adams and
Jefferson they had I think a kind of
utilitarian view of religion so whether
each one I'm eeen how how devout each
was in their own personal life can be
disputed but what can't be disputed I
think is that they is that they did
think that that that religion could
serve a useful purpose and function in
society not everybody can be at John
Adams or at Thomas Jefferson
not everybody can be a philosopher and
so I think ultimately in the end what
they did was they attempted to reconcile
philosophy and religion yeah so this
seems to be a little bit of the macro
micro argument on religion and morality
so we've done this a couple times in
this very studio where I've had Dennis
Prager and Michael Shermer on where
Michael comes from the point of that you
can have be completely moral without
religion right Dennis says that at the
micro level you right there can be but
in at a societal level on the macro
level that it doesn't quite work it
sounds like there's a little bit of that
idea in there no I mean I think III
think that's right in terms of the
founding fathers though I think there's
there's really no question
that that that they thought that that
religion and philosophy would have to be
reconciled in in some kind of way that
were to put it differently that Athens
and Jerusalem right would have to be
reconciled reason and revelation now
whether the philosopher can actually
whether whether the philosopher actually
thinks that in fact is true is a
completely different question so can
there can there be both moral virtue and
freedom without religion well I think
absolutely there can be and but the
question is how do you convince three
hundred and fifty million rather of your
fellow citizens of that and and how how
do you get them to be to actually be
moral in their lives here now today
without without without that crutch now
I think there are ways and do you think
so is that right there is that sort of
the the linchpin of everything else that
John Adams believed do you think that's
sort of his most important post that he
staked in hindsight given the context of
the world in which we live today yeah I
think we have a lot to learn from Adams
and in fact it's really just only been
in the last couple of weeks that I've
decided that I'm a not certain yet but I
may be writing in what I would call a
moral biography of John Adams and the
purpose of which is to introduce to 21st
century Americans particularly the kind
of audience that Jordan Pederson is
appealing to introducing to them at the
very least introducing to them the moral
seriousness of this extraordinary
generation of Americans
there's a sense in which there's a sense
in which and I think particularly in the
context of the world in which we live
today
politics is becoming increasingly
irrelevant if not or secondary and if
there's going to be I mean you've talked
about an idea revolution and I think a
big part of that idea revolution has to
be a kind of moral revolution and you
know as Breitbart Andrew Breitbart
famously said you know cult politics is
down I'll go even further economics is
downstream from politics politics is
downstream from culture and culture is
downstream from ideas and ideas are
housed in the universities and if we if
there's going to be an idea revolution I
think it has to begin with morality and
we need a kind of in an age of nihilism
I do think we need a kind of moral
revolution and one way to get at it
would be to go back to our founding
fathers yeah well that's why I wanted to
do so many of the founders in this first
presidents week that we're doing and
obviously this particular topic fits
within the sort of larger thing that
we're doing here what else do we need to
know about his sense of morality I mean
what did he really believe those tenants
to be well I mean he formulated it in
different ways at different times but I
think one could probably sum up his
moral view with three pillars believe in
God be kind to other people and govern
yourself but Adams really only focused
on the third one right which is
interesting if you if you read his diary
his autobiography all of his political
writings and more and maybe even more
importantly if you read the advice that
that he gives to his own children like
for instance in letters to his son John
Quincy Adams
when John Quincy was a young boy 13 when
when he's sending John Quincy Adams
advice you know on how to become a young
man the focus the emphasis is almost
entirely on how to govern oneself and
how do you govern oneself or what it for
instance what are the books that one can
read well it's it's never the Bible it
is Aristotle Nicomachean ethics Cicero
cicero's de o'fee key Seneca and
epictetus so ancient Greek and Roman
yeah moral philosophers in other words
pre-christian pagan moralist and yet he
has this important religious piece
that's hatched to him in seemingly a
more intimate way I guess that's what
I'm finding it seems like he had it in a
more personal way than some of the other
founders did yeah well certainly more
than Jefferson that that that is I think
that is that is true and but probably
more so he had probably he certainly had
a little slightly more religion I mean
he almost Adams was almost a deist he
wasn't quite as as much of a deist this
Thomas Jefferson was but look there that
were there revolutionaries and founding
fathers who were Calvinists of course
there were right where their founding
fathers who were more religious more
devout than Adams was absolutely and so
I would say on the spectrum of religious
belief Adams was I would say closer to
Jefferson's position in the end for
Adams Adams as Christianity came down to
belief in the existence of God the
immortality of souls right that the soul
is immortal
and that when we die we will be rewarded
or punished for our virtues or our sins
but that's it right it's even
questionable whether he believed
the divinity of Christ so his religion
he went to church he unlike Jefferson he
was a regular churchgoer but he was I
you know he really was very close to
being a deist and and really and this is
the point to make there's a much greater
emphasis in his moral writings his moral
teachings on what I called earlier a
kind of secular science of ethics yeah
so you mentioned some of the things that
he was reading what do we know about the
contemporaries or some of the people
ahead of him that he was learning from
in in terms of terms of learning
political philosophy Harvard I would
have also imagined that unlike say James
Madison who came from a lot of money
coming from nothing ending up at Harvard
that must have been pretty unheard of to
write oh absolutely
right and and so I mean it is an
interesting contrast between Adams for
instance so if you if you look at the
major founding fathers yeah and let's
take Washington Jefferson and Madison
all three from Virginia all three
aristocrats all three slaveholders John
Adams by contrast comes from very modest
means right his father was a what we
would call a yeoman yeoman farmer sort
of lower middle class farmer they lived
very very modest lives Adams I mean he
did not have a lot and he really he was
recognized by his father at a very young
age as as being really quite brilliant
right so and he was and because John
Adams was the oldest son it was
determined by the father that he would
that that he would go too far that he
would go to Harvard the father wanted
him to be a minister and that was part
of his struggle during his time at
Harvard and after he graduated for those
three years in Worcester was do I become
a minister that was I mean that was
really
sort of what inspired him to start
thinking seriously about his religious
commitments and about a year into his
teaching in Wooster he he decided no I'm
not going to be a minister I'm not gonna
be a minister because I don't imagine
what it's like to be a minister in
eighteenth-century Massachusetts you are
going to be involved in theological
disputes you know all the time and he
witnessed those theological disputes and
he said that's not for me so he decided
to become to become a lawyer yeah
so his he was a practicing lawyer well
it sounds like all the font the founders
basically were we're lawyers at some
level or another and that that was
really the direct link to politics right
correct yeah at that time so in what's
interesting though is that there were no
law schools at that time right so what
you to become a lawyer you apprenticed
you would you would apprentice with with
a lawyer which Adams did for he
apprenticed with a lawyer first and in
Worcester and then when he moved back to
Braintree and Boston he apprenticed and
you know and again I mean when reading
his diary
I mean David's extraordinary what this
young man was was like and the kind of
work ethic that was required to to
dedicate oneself particularly coming
from modest means right so unlike unlike
Jefferson right who who I mean really
was in many ways kind of you know he was
I I call him the Virginia dolphin he was
sort of the heir apparent I mean he was
he was he was raised mostly by women he
was pampered and and treated you know as
though he really were an aristocrat
whereas Adams had to struggle for
everything in his life and he had to
work extraordinarily hard and
his commitment to and he's doing this
right not at a law school right where if
you remember the famous professor
Kingsfield yeah in the great movie the
Paper Chase right there's no professor
Kingsfield in his life there is there's
just a kind of individual personal
commitment and again in his diary I mean
he shares this he tells you how he does
it yeah and if I could just share with
you this one extraordinary story about
Adams that that has always moved me and
and I share with my students all the
time Adams was a young Adams again 21 22
year old Adams is he was always
fascinated with this ancient fable
called the choice of Hercules which was
first told in Xenophon's memorabilia and
then was captured on canvas in I think
the 16th century by the by the painter
anabolic kurachi and so what is the
choice of Hercules what is the the
painting right the painting of it's
Hercules sitting and to his left is vice
in the form of a very attractive woman
wearing a very sort of silky negligee
kind of thing and there's a mask
representing the theater and a bottle of
wine and to his right there is a very
sturdy modest modestly dressed woman who
represents virtue and she's pointing
upward to a mountain and a road that
that Criss crosses up the mountain and
for Adam's this he was fascinated by the
choice of Hercules and this kind of
summed up his the conflicts in his life
and so let me just reach over now and in
his diary and I would like to share this
with you and and your your audience
remember 21 years old keep writing in
this diary how many 21 year olds
would write this in their diary today
yeah all right
he writes let virtue address me which
dear youth will you prefer a life of
effeminacy indolence and obscurity or a
life of Industry temperance and honor
take my advice let no trifling diversion
or amusement or company to coy you from
your books that is let no girl no gun no
cards no flutes no violins no dress no
tobacco no laziness to coy you from your
books and then the very next passage
right he lays out all of the the great
treatises of the law that he that he has
to study and and he's constantly sort of
imploring himself examining sort of the
inner status of his soul trying to purge
himself of all laziness so that he can
return to the books and become the best
and he has a vision at a very young age
he has a vision of greatness in fact he
lays out he establishes a hierarchy of
greatness of different professions right
and at the peak at the pinnacle of the
hierarchy of greatness is talk-show host
that was the number two yeah that was
number two professor was number one no
professor was not number one professor
didn't even make the list oh no it was
to be a lawgiver and by which he meant a
lawgiver in the tradition of the great
classical Greek law givers like Kyrgyz
of Sparta and so lon of Athens and what
did like her cousin Solon do they were
constitution makers they designed the
constitutions for Sparta and for Athens
and so Adams in round 1759 1760 decides
that he wants to be a lawgiver a
constitution maker and if you think
about it in the context of what will
come almost 20 years later it's it's a
kind of its prophetic yeah
he really gave himself a roadmap for
this thing he did yeah
so the passage that you just read and
much of what you reference here that
this was all in his biography so he was
just writing this to himself yeah in his
diary it is of course in his biography
his diary yes so at the time he didn't
even know that this was I mean I guess
they all sort of knew it was gonna be
public at some level if things went well
right no III don't know I don't think he
was thinking at 21 that this will be
public I'll be great I mean I think he
was honestly genuinely confronting
confronting the the biggest questions of
his life at that time and I think he was
entirely genuine and he was using the
diary as a vehicle for self-improvement
do we know what some of the other guys
like Jefferson and Madison thought of
him because he came from such a
different place I mean I there probably
was a little Envy there perhaps or a
little dismissiveness of the type of
person that he was just because of his
roots yeah although sort of never it was
never expressed quite in those terms so
were many envious of him absolutely did
many of them denounce him unquestionably
what is I think most interesting and I
think maybe we can get into this later
because it's connected to his later
political thought which he developed 20
25 years later is in the irony of this
is is stinging he was accused for
instance by Thomas Jefferson of being an
advocate of aristocracy and monarchy of
being a crypto monarchist of being an
apostate - or a heretic terms Jefferson
used in describing a time of the
Republican cause now I mean this is this
is of course a fundamentally it rots
absurd and it's dishonest because what
was the basis for the accusation well
the the basis was came out of things
that that were misinterpreted that Adams
had written in the late 1780s so you
know Adams wrote a great treatise called
a defense of the Constitution's of the
United States of America in which if
read shall in a very shallow way and
without really reading what Adams is
actually saying one well let's just say
some misinterpreted what he wrote and
and claimed that he was arguing for
these things which which he absolutely
was not all right so I think we've set a
pretty good table here in terms of the
sort of battle he had between internal
morality and religion and how he
combined these things and the people
that were around him at his background
and all that as we enter sort of the
Revolutionary period here he was one of
the first people that wanted
independence from Britain right
absolutely yeah and it was that just he
wanted personal freedom so he wanted
freedom from the old world yeah so he
was I mean I think in part he was always
looking for a launching pad to the
launching pad to greatness in a sense
and that came in 1770 1765 with the
passage of the Stamp Act the famous
Stamp Act and he wrote his first major
treatise in 1765 was called a
dissertation on the Canon in feudal law
and it was it was first a critique of
the Stamp Act and what he did was he
just lay out what this antithetical yeah
sure the Stamp Act was passed by the the
British Parliament in 1765 and what it
did was it put a tax a first-time-ever
tax on anglo-american Colonials on on
the use of papers so all paper
particularly paper that was used in
legal transactions had to be crowned
stamped so stamped right paper and what
was from the American perspective what
was
unjust about this about this tax was
that they had never been taxed by Great
Britain before Britain had always
Britain had various commercial
regulations where they had duties on
goods imported into the colonies but
never attacks for the purpose of raising
a revenue for the British Treasury so
this was truly the first example of no
taxation without representation
no taxation without representation I
can't imagine that he had much pushback
against that from his his friends and
capade trees right everyone was against
it yeah well for the most part right for
the most part most almost all Americans
recognized the injustice of the Stamp
Act but what happened was that the the
following year the British Parliament
because of the reaction in America which
was immediate
it was visceral and occasionally it was
violent so there were protests up and
down the Atlantic seaboard from Boston
to Charleston so the following year they
rescinded the Stamp Act but passed a new
act called the declaratory act which
declared that Parliament's laws were
supreme in all cases whatsoever and what
that meant was that that Parliament was
now declaring that they were supreme
their Authority their power was supreme
over the thirteen colonial legislatures
and so in many ways of all the acts
passed by the British Parliament during
this period that we call the Imperial
crisis from 1765 to 1776 which would
include in addition to the Stamp Act the
Townsend Acts the Tea Act the coercive
acts in many ways the declaratory act
was the one that concerned the Americans
the most because it essentially took
away their freedom of self-government
right and the Americans over the course
of the previous
fifty years had really developed even
though they were loyal subjects of the
British crown they had really developed
a kind of independence from Great
Britain they were governing themselves
and and during that period up until 1765
during the period of what they call
salutary neglect Britain took a very
lazy fair attitude toward the the
American colonies which you know allowed
them to develop all these self-governing
institutions and traditions and so
that's why when the Stamp Act came it
just it was it set off a firestorm in in
the colonies and then beginning with the
Adams his dissertation on the Canon in
feudal law which in the end was not only
a critique of a Stamp Act but I would
say even more importantly it was a
defence of American liberty and Adams
introduces the idea of what he called
the spirit of Liberty which he was
trying to to reignite in the American
people and the spirit of Liberty is a
combination of having certain ideas of
right and and just but also combining it
with a kind of passion a love of freedom
and so Adams was very explicitly
reigniting this spirit of Liberty and
from that moment forward you can trace
his trajectory right to right to the
revolution
yeah let's go let me let's go to the
revolution take take me on that boy yeah
so for the rest of the 1760s adams with
every passing year becomes increasingly
more involved in the local massachusetts
more particularly boston revolutionary
movement so he gets elected to the
Massachusetts legislature and I think
1770 he's writing all kinds of pamphlets
defending American freedom freedom and
attacking the idea of parliamentary
sovereignty a couple was it dangerous to
do things like that at the time I mean
like physically dangerous I mean I was
obviously cannot traverse old I'm sure
there were people that didn't like him
but you know sort of think about it in
our times now if you were
hang out some really anti-government
stuff like yeah you know yet not then it
would become dangerous by 1775 it then
very much becomes dangerous and
absolutely in 1776 yeah but in the 1760s
no it's it's it's not dangerous but it
would for instance get in the way of
one's professional and personal
development so for instance in 1769
Adams is offered the position of
Advocate General in the courts of
Admiralty which which during any other
period of colonial American history
would have been an extraordinary boon to
a young men of extraordinarily modest
means I mean this was this was to reach
the the pinnacle of British imperial
government in the college but he refused
and he refused he said because he could
not and would not sanction policies that
were against the freedoms of what he
called to his country and then a year
later after the Boston Massacre and once
again sort of against maybe against his
immediate interest he defends the
British soldiers in the court of law
against against murder charges and he
successfully defends them and he defends
them right and at the same time he's
doing this his own fellow Patriots are
denouncing him for defending British
soldiers who were involved in the Boston
Massacre but Adams said that in a free
country every man deserves justice yeah
he must have gotten incredible amount of
hate for that he got a fair amount of
hate for that right so those two stories
I think are early indications of Adams
a--'s moral integrity right Adams was a
man of extraordinary moral and political
integrity he had principles
in symbols that he believed in but more
importantly principles that he lived his
life by right and so for Adams and and
you know this is an important point for
Adams one self-interest was not
necessarily once a financial gain or
improvement one self-interest was in
protecting one's moral character and so
Adams unlike almost all the other
founding fathers always put himself in a
position where I mean he was risking he
was risking fortune reputation but he
always did it because he believed the
cause was true and right yeah I would
imagine as he was defending the British
soldiers that he probably thought and if
I'll probably never get into politics
after this ya know that's right and he
did he did take a lot of heat from some
of some of the local Patriots but but he
was so committed to the cause and then
in 1774 75 he wrote what I think is
still to this day the most importance
certainly I think the most brilliant
Revolutionary tract that was published
it was the title is the no Vangelis
letters and Adams at a very high
theoretical level took up the biggest
questions the biggest constitutional
questions that existed because the
battle between Great Britain and the
colonies at that time was primarily a
constitutional question right and it
came down to one question what is the
extent of Parliament's Authority in the
American colonies and Adams in an
evangelist letters develops an
incredibly sophisticated legal argument
arguing that the colony that Parliament
has no authority in the colonies
whatsoever none hmm
and in fact argues that the colonies
only connection to Great Britain was and
this is very interesting and ironic
through the person of the king that is
to say
Parliament has no authority that can
make no laws for us our only attachment
to Great Britain is really through our
charters charters that have been granted
by by English kings in the 17th century
and these charters are in effect for the
4 atoms they are proto constitutions and
these charters define for atoms the
constitutional relationship between
Great Britain and in the colonies so
these charters these were the original
rules that they were governed by yes
yeah so in effect he was gonna get rid
of them I think they were all gonna get
rid of them anyway right well yeah well
by that time now that's right that what
I think that was close to being oh I see
what you're saying so he basically was
saying yeah it's that old stuff those
charters but that's it they're there
yeah no that's that exactly right right
and but eventually Adams scraps the
charges and by the way I mean just very
quickly and let me say that that these
charters are I mean these are legal
documents
English legal documents and but what
Adams does and this is writ was this is
the most philosophically interesting
part of the new Vangelis letters he
reinterprets them to be Lockean social
contracts right there there are less
legal documents and they're philosophic
documents they are grounded in
individuals coming together in communal
association and through consent agreeing
to establish first communities and then
a Lockean social compact with with the
king but these these charters by Adams
interpretation give the colonists full
self governing authority in the colonies
so anyway it's the most I think it's the
most important tract of the
Revolutionary period do we know after
that how much actual editing or writing
he did on the directly on the
Constitution or the Bill of Rights yes
so zero technically yeah so he was with
Thomas Jefferson he was not at the
Constitutional Convention in 1787 so
where was he he was he was in Europe he
was he was ambassador to to Great
Britain at the time and Jefferson was
ambassador to France at the time but
Adams his ideas however had a massive
influence on the drafting of the Federal
Constitution so in 1776 Adams wrote this
is before July 4th so before
independence Adams is the leading
advocate in the Continental Congress for
for the colonies to draft constitutions
and create new governments which was in
effect a de facto Declaration of
Independence in to that end he drafted a
document or a pamphlet called thoughts
on government and it's a kind of proto
Constitution and it it was in many ways
other than Tom Paine's Common Sense it
was the most influential pamphlet
written during I think the Revolutionary
period because it influenced the
drafting of revolutionary state
constitutions in four states and then in
1780 Adams himself is the author of the
most important the most developed in the
most influential revolutionary state
constitution which was the Massachusetts
Constitution which then had a direct
influence both in form and substance for
the federal constitution of 1787 so
after the Revolution he then becomes the
first vice president am I missing
anything between there did I yeah yeah
oh my god Dave you missed some stuff
yeah I know yeah yeah yeah there's
there's still a lot so so I'll pick up
just before July 4th 1776 so Adams has
been now in the Second Continental
Congress for for two years he's he's
moved away from Abigail his wife and
their four young children he's moved to
Philadelphia and I think it is
absolutely the case that Adams was he
was the engine the workhorse of the the
revolutionary movement between 7:00 1774
and 1776 he served on some 90 committees
during that time he lived very modestly
in a boarding house working 12 14 hours
a day six days a week and but the great
moments and in many ways Adams his
greatest contribution to the American
Revolution which has gone entirely
neglected by by historians is I mean the
great moment of independence is not July
4th it's actually July 1st because that
was the day when arguments were going to
be taken up in the Continental Congress
for or against independence and John
Dickinson who was from Delaware and who
himself had been one of the intellectual
leaders of the revolutionary movement up
until that point stood up and gave a
three-hour speech against Independence
Dickinson was a kind of moderate or
cautious revolutionary we might say
after he sat down the room fell silent
and everybody sort of very nervously
looked around the room who would be the
person to stand up and argue for
independence because the person who
stood up to argue for independence would
be of course reported to George 1/3 as a
man who's making the argument for
independence and will us were just like
what was Dickinson's argument basically
that just we shouldn't do this now
because it's out because he was a
revolutionary and maybe not like he
would have wanted freedom right yeah for
sure absolutely
he was a reconciliation aside that that
patriot revolutionaries like John Adams
and his cousin Samuel Adams were pushing
too hard too fast and that there was
still time for reconciliation and but
the Adams cousins and Thomas Jefferson
as well and George Washington
interestingly enough they they believed
but and this is particularly now in the
light of Concord and Lexington right
Concord and Lexington had been had taken
place in I think April 1775 year before
so armed conflict had already begun in
in in the colonies in Massachusetts in
particular when we'd already had the
Battle of Bunker Hill and all that stuff
so bloodshed had already happened so at
this point for Adams the rubic Rubicon
had been crossed certainly with the
battles in in Massachusetts the Rubicon
was passed and he was full full steam
ahead for for independence so in this in
in in the Congress meeting in
Philadelphia you know everybody's very
nervously looking around the room right
who in a who is going to be demand to
stand up and be and and essentially be
committing treason because if this
doesn't go your way you're essentially
signing your own death warrant correct
certain level certainly your political
life and probably your real life ya know
that's exactly right but then all eyes
eventually turned on the one man who
they knew would stand up the one man who
had the integrity the honor and the
courage and of course was John Adams and
John Adams
stood up and he gave this kind of fiery
argument for independence spoke for Anik
an hour and a half
Thomas Jefferson described this speech
as as having he said quote moved us from
our seats and he described Adams as the
Colossus of of independence another
delegate who was there and witnessed
Adams of speech described Adams as the
Atlas of Independence and so I think in
many ways well in fact not in many ways
I'll just said I think this is the
greatest speech in American history it's
the most consequential speech in
American history now I see why you
didn't want me to skip right over to VP
exactly and then the next day the
Congress votes votes for independence so
Adams and then during this whole period
from from let's say 75 to 77 now post
post independence Adams was he was a
workaholic and as I said he served on 90
committees most importantly he served he
was the president of the board of war
and ordinance which means that he he
logistically ran the war so he his job
was to supply Washington's army with
supplies and it was you know it was more
than a full-time job during that time he
and by the way it was John Adams who
nominated George Washington to be
commander of the American forces during
this time Adams also developed what was
known as the model treaty which was this
which which became the the most
influential treaty or model of a treaty
almost throughout all of American
history because it argued that America
should never have what it called
entangling alliances so Adams was I mean
I mean he was the most active and
principled of revolutionary during this
time and you have to also keep in mind
and this really is extraordinary
he's living apart from his wife and
young
young family I mean he was away from
them for almost two years he rode by
horseback round-trip from Boston to
Philadelphia almost always in the dead
of winter a two-week trip five times
during this period so I mean he really
was
yeah the work engine of the revolution
and then now fast forward to the late
1770s he was appointed by the
Continental Congress as a Minister
Plenipotentiary to go to Europe and help
try and get France to ally with with
these now rebel Americans that couldn't
have been a fun job well it's
extraordinary I mean it I mean the
stories that I'm about to share with you
I mean are literally unbelievable and it
tells you everything you need to know
about demand John Adams so Adams first
goes to France in 1778 the ship there
the the ship that he took and he went
with his his son John Quincy Adams he
took him and the ship's main mast was
struck by a lightning bolt destroyed the
main mast and the ship could could
barely sail they were attacked by the
British Navy
Adams you know who was the most
distinguished I mean I mean he was the
prized possession on the ship that it
was the responsibility of the captain to
make sure he got Adams to France
Adams insisted on going above deck and
and fighting and you know literally
cannonballs
and we have a record of this cannonballs
were whizzing over Adams his head and
the captain told go go below deck and
Adams refused he said if you know if
other men are gonna fight and die for
the cause so will I Wow
so he goes to France he's only there for
six months is recalled comes back
and then is told now that he has to go
to France again one more time and by the
way you have to remember he's doing a
North Atlantic crossing in these leaky
leaky rickety old ships the second trip
to France and this is this is really
extraordinary he decides now he's going
to take two of his sons john quincy
who's 12 and charles who is eight three
days outside of boston the ship is in a
major storm a three day storm it springs
a leak all hands on deck have to pump
water for two weeks and and this is in
the middle of a war and britain has the
largest most powerful Navy in the world
so they have to sail basically through
through the british block blockade the
ship was supposed to sail to bordeaux
france it can't make it to bordeaux so
it goes to the northwestern corner of
spain el farol Spain where Adams and his
two sons disembark Adams now has a
choice he can wait a month for the ship
to be repaired to sail to Bordeaux or
John Adams and his 12 year old and eight
year old sons decide that they're going
to take the overland route and so Adams
and his two boys set off on donkeys
unbelievable and ride from west to east
across northern Spain they then and and
along the way they're staying in in
Spanish boarding houses I mean can you
imagine what a bore a Spanish border
boarding house in northern Spain in the
18th century would be like Adams
describes that they had they had
fireplaces with no chimneys and the all
the animals slept in the houses so he
it's extraordinary
yeah at one point that you know they
have to cross the Pyrenees in the middle
of the winter John Quincy Adams in the
diary says that at one point going over
the mountains on donkeys we were
perpendicular
right they eventually get over the
Pyrenees Mountains and again I mean a
man imagine an eight-year-old at a 12 an
eight-year-old in a 12 year old riding
donkeys across the Pyrenees Mountains in
the middle of the winter they come over
and they get into France they get into a
little village called song Jean de Luz
and from there they take a coach and for
as it was called comparison a thousand
mile trip how long did this whole thing
take it took I think it took them a
months so basically he could have waited
oh I guess waited a month for repairs
and then still had to sail yeah the day
before or something yeah I might it
might have been too much side yeah I
don't remember now but I mean it's an
extraordinary story and it demonstrates
Adams is commitment to the revolutionary
cause right that and and it tells us
something about his moral character
right that he was willing to do just
about anything and everything for the
sake of the American Revolution so he
gets to Paris and Adams was not the most
diplomatic of a mayor of America's
revolutionary diplomats right
by contrast Benjamin Franklin and Thomas
Jefferson were the epitome of diplomacy
as defined by the French but Yankee John
who was honest to a fault he just he
couldn't play the diplomatic game is
Thomas Jefferson the ambassador at this
time no Jefferson is not Jefferson is
not quite yet in France Jefferson will
come a few years later okay but Franklin
Franklin right there okay yeah so Adams
was not a great success at the court of
louis xvi so he decided he would leave
France and instead go to the Netherlands
where he conducted what he called
militia diplomacy and he spent first the
first year trying to get the Dutch Dutch
bankers to commit to funding the
American Revolution which he was six
fled doing and then he finally got the
Dutch government to to recognize the the
American the American Revolution and
during that that that I think two three
year period that he was in Holland I
mean he was he was a workaholic I mean
he's working now seven days a week he's
working 16-hour days he actually got
malaria and was deathly ill during his
time there but it was his performance as
a European diplomat despite the fact
that he broke all the rules of diplomacy
despite the fact that he you know that
he was not a let's call it a manicured
diplomat I mean he got the bottom line
is he got the job done and then he is
appointed to be the first ambassador to
the court of st. James in Britain so he
goes he goes to Britain in I think 1785
where he serves as the diplomat
America's ambassador to to Britain and
if I could one more yeah one more quick
story which I again I'm trying to share
with you and your audience the
extraordinary character of this man yeah
well that's I like word that we're
getting a sense of a little real person
here not just the political philosophy
yeah yeah so in 1780 in 1784 85 he'd
already made several North Sea crossings
in the winter which is a brutal crossing
to have to make and he has to go back
one last time to secure more loans from
Dutch bankers and he boards ship he's
deathly ill but he does it and again a
day out of out of port the ship hits a
massive storm and they are that the ship
gets close to Holland but is effectively
shipwrecked on a deserted island and
Adams
and and his the crew they get out on
this island they trekked and Adams is
now I mean I you know he's close to 50
and they had to Trek break snow
knee-deep snow for 8 miles to get to a
small village where they got a car which
took him to the far end of the island
they get to the far end of the island
then they have to rent ice boats because
the channel between the island and the
mainland is filled with ice and these
ice boats have runners on the bottom of
them right so they row row where there's
water until they get to ice right and
then somebody has to get out pull the
boat up onto the ice then they have to
walk across ice and then they get to
water again then they have to get back
in the boat the boat goes back into the
water and they and and then they have to
repeat this you know let's say five
times ten times over
but again it just debt that kind of
story I think demonstrates the man and
you have to understand the man in
contrast to to say other revolutionaries
Thomas Jefferson for instance
essentially sat out the war after he
wrote the Declaration of Independence he
left Philadelphia and basically lived at
Monticello for the rest of the war
mm-hmm he was governor of Virginia for a
couple of years but that was it it so
sat out the war whereas Adams was more
with the exception I guess of George
Washington was more intimately involved
in in the everyday workings of the
revolution than any other American
revolutionary at the time yeah that's
incredible so was he basically a
no-brainer when Washington was deciding
who his VP was yeah yeah I mean it
wasn't unanimous and when when the vote
was made all right because at the time
yeah it wasn't just George Washington
that selected his BP
they were votes yeah yeah that's right
but but it was I mean it was clear that
the only person who was gonna be
President the first President of the
United States was gonna be George
washing right right and the only
question who was gonna be who was the
vice president and Adams got this the
second largest number of votes which
made him so they had a different voting
system then so he became the vice
president and of course it was a balance
between a Virginian and somebody from
New England and it was it was an
extraordinary cabinet that Washington
selected because he made Jefferson's
Secretary of State and Alexander
Hamilton secretary of the Treasury yeah
I mean just power houses it was it's
just hard to believe that you know with
government now it's hard to believe that
there was so much there a final thought
I mean just give me something on his
actual presidency that we should know
because it seems like so much of it and
so much of what you write about is pre
presidency is there anything major that
we need to know about the president yeah
so Adams was only president for one term
I think the first thing to note is that
it was it was not it was it was a term
with a lot of problems and and the
biggest problem that he was that he was
surrounded by enemies in his own own
administration I mean think about it
you follow George Washington right who
follows George Washington it probably
was at the height of his popularity
because he got another power of the the
military that's why people must have he
was beyond canonized that yeah exactly
but what happened was America
essentially throughout the 1790s early
to mid 1790s divided it divided along
party lines and they were there were two
parties there were the Democratic
Republicans the titular head of which
was Thomas Jefferson and there was the
Federalist Party and Alexander Hamilton
was effectively the leader of the
Federalist Party John Adams saw himself
as being a man above party but the
problem was his administration was full
of the the leaders of the two parties so
Thomas Jefferson was his vice president
and then all Hamilton's followers were
in his cabinet so he was constantly
being torn apart by these two competing
wings now the big crisis that took place
in the 1790s was effectively a foreign
policy crisis so by the time Adams
became president France had begun what
came to be called a quasi war against
the United States that is banned because
the United States had in the 1790s
signed a treaty to the Jay Treaty with
Great Britain and had reestablished
commercial relations so what happened
was and now you have a revolutionary
government in France and this
revolutionary government unleashed its
Navy on American commercial trading and
so they were attacking American ships
and so it was a it was a foreign policy
crisis and so Adams had to navigate this
crisis and the Federalists in his
administration wanted him to go to war
with France Jefferson and his followers
wanted him to to not go to war with
France and he was he was caught in the
middle and eventually long story short
he he developed a foreign policy that
wouldn't refuse to listen to either
party and he eventually established a
treaty with France which ended the quasi
war but you know I think your your
viewers are gonna want to ask me about
the Alien and Sedition Acts yes right
so the Alien and Sedition Acts were were
passed at the end of Adams
administration and of course Adams has
been pilloried he was at the time and
he's been pilloried throughout American
history because up to this day because
of
the passage of the Alien and Sedition
Acts particularly the Sedition Act so
but you have to understand the to
understand why Adams signed the Alien
and Sedition Act you have to under the
Act part of it extended the period of
naturalization for foreigners from I
think say three years to fourteen or
sixteen years but it also gave the
government the the power and the
authority to deport subversives in the
United States the Sedition Act gave the
federal government the the authority to
arrest people usually newspaper editors
who were committing seditious libel
against the government right this is the
dangerous one well it is the dangerous
one but you have to under to really
understand it you have to put it in
context and which is the context of the
time the first thing to note is that the
alien is Sedition Act was a it was it
was a war measure because the United
States was in the it was in a quasi war
and you also have to understand at this
time that the United States Philadelphia
in particular where the government was
at the time Philadelphia was a city that
was full of French revolutionaries who
were arguing for revolution in in the
United States along the same lines as
the French Revolution which it was in
the middle of the terror right which it
was in the middle of committing genocide
in in France and at one point there was
a protest a violent protest in
Philadelphia which is you know at the
time would have been a small city of
twenty-five fifty thousand people that
was a it is estimated there was a
demonstration of ten thousand people in
Philadelphia supporting the French
Revolution which went to John Adams as
house and Adams had to gar had to have
armed guards protecting him from these
revolutionaries anyway that's the
context so it was a war measure with a
sunset clause it was only to go into
effect for two years
so that's the that's the first thing the
second thing which most people don't
understand is that the Sedition Act was
actually a liberalization of current
Sedition law right so in in Sedition law
of the time truth was not permitted as a
defense but the new Sedition Act allowed
for truth so in fact it actually
liberalized yes Sedition law it improved
it and the other thing to mention just
very quickly that Adam is that Adams it
won it was not Adams idea this was the
the creature of the high Federalists in
Congress it was a law created by
Congress Adams never never supported it
in theory or in practice eventually yes
he did sign it and that was his great
mistake without question but he was
never a supporter of it the last thing
to say Thomas Jefferson who attacked
Adams for the Sedition Acts it should be
noted did not oppose the Sedition Act
because on free speech grounds he
opposed the Sedition Act because it was
passed by the federal government
Jefferson was a hundred percent okay
with Sedition Acts Sedition laws at the
state level and in fact when he was
president he he sent a note to the
governor of Pennsylvania demanding that
the governor use state Sedition laws to
to silence anti Jeffersonian editors in
Pennsylvania so anyway yeah it shows how
they all had these sort of conflicting
and complex beliefs that sometimes we're
completing and complexed for the amount
to their own selves yeah absolutely so
it's it's it's a little more complex
than we think about it today and judged
by the standards of the time it's more
understandable judged by our standards
today and certainly you and I as
advocates of free speech looking look at
horror with at the sedition laws but
yeah Wow Wow I mean there's so much here
and I really love that we did this sort
of
has been a little bit different than
some of the other ones we've done
because we really went at the man and
not just the idea so I really enjoyed
this chat and I suspect we will perhaps
do this again in Clemson in the
not-too-distant future I'd look forward
to it perhaps we shall see
for more on Brad we've linked to John
Adams and the spirit of Liberty as well
as the revolutionary writings of John
Adams right down below
[Music]
you